well I think very similarly in the sense
of it's definitely put me on the
American side of the Japanese American
divide in the sense that America is
obviously lightyears ahead of Japan in
terms of where we are in gay rights but
I think more deeply it's given me a
profound sense of how important it is to
live in a society that honors difference
and is able to see differences as
strengths rather than as a weakness one
of the things that has always troubled
me and continues to trouble me about
Japan is how difficult it is to be
different in any way whatsoever there
and that can range from being a woman
being of a different race being of a
different nationality even within the
same race if you look at the treatment
of Koreans in Japan obviously being gay
but even to very very things that we
would think of as being completely
within the discretion of the individual
sort of very personal things like
hairstyle or dress and if you are
outside of the box in any way you very
quickly get driven back into line the
Japanese proverb is the protruding nail
gets pummeled and I think that one of
the things that I love about this
country and really our constitutional
tradition is that you can be quite
different before you get you know push
back into line in that way
that's actually a great question because
I think it's that question that we're
wrestling with a lot these days and our
national politics because I guess I need
to backtrack a little bit and to say
that I would say that for some purposes
gayness is an identity and for others it
is not so I would say that when I go out
into the world I understand that I code
as a gay man and I self-identify as a
gay man because there's a fight being
fought in this country and it's really
important to self-identify yourself in a
way that allows you to be a role model
to other people that allows you to make
certain kinds of arguments you know
because you have the standing to make
them and so on and so forth
but on the other hand I like the
question because there's so many other
ways in which I think that it isn't an
identity and increasingly if you look at
the generation that's below me so I'm
thinking about people who are just
coming of age now you know entering
college or in the early 20s who really
think of being gay as completely
tangential to their existence and they
don't accept it as an identity there's
an increasing movement of saying I
choose not to label my sexuality I'm
just gonna fall in love with whoever I
fall in love with I'm gonna have sex
with who I want to have sex with and
that shouldn't be consequential for my
career it shouldn't be consequential for
my family you know obviously there are
complications if you're with someone of
the same sex in terms of you know
reproductive technologies and things
like that but that could also be true
between a man and a woman if either of
them we're having difficulty procreating
and so it's become akin to that and so I
think that that is a really interesting
generational shift that we're looking at
one of the things that I still think is
really important though in terms of
identifying as a gay man is that the
fight is far from over and you know
whether or not we in the ivory tower
wanna theorize this as a status ie I'm
gay or a conduct you know I engage in
certain forms of behavior the practical
political reality is that politics
occurs around groups and that we have to
Ally ourselves as being on one side of
that battle or the other